The Bible, we see that god is
indeed good.
However, the reality of human suffering is actually the
consequence of sin already entering the world.
Human disobedience
LED to this broken relationship that we have with god
and the introduction of pain and suffering.
But Alamo, God in his goodness
was the one who provided the solution
through Jesus Christ.
So while we may not fully understand
why specific sufferings occur in our lives,
the Bible assures us that
god works all things together for the good
of those who love him.
The bar we can find comfort in knowing that god is
indeed good
and that his
ultimate plan is for us to have this eternal joy
as long as we trust in him.
Have you recently shared with someone how Jesus
strengthen your faith in the midst of suffering?
Let us know in the comments or send us a message.